good evening from New York welcome to PE
Morgan uncensored whether we monarchist
Brits like to admit it or not the
president of the United States is the
single most important person in the
world commanding the world's mest
military and holding the perrings of its
biggest economy the president could end
Israel's war in Gaza with a phone call
or decide if Ukraine gets the backing it
needs to beat Putin at least that's the
general idea but the current Commander
in Chief is 81 seemingly going on 181 of
a lifetime of distinguished public
service as a pragmatic politician and in
my view a thoroughly decent human being
President Biden looks increasingly unfit
for service and with the president
invisible decline his reelection
campaign is well transitioning you might
say it pronouns are changing before our
very eyes the two most important women
in President Biden's life have been sent
out to jump start the 2024 race wildly
unpopular VP carela Harris said this
we've got 10 months to go until the
election M and increasingly and you've
seen it even just this week um we are
all starting to narrow in on what this
election will mean yeah and it's going
to be the choice
between what is about respecting our
democracy what is about competence
versus
chaos well the vice president is Right
competence is crucially important but
her own boss has trouble getting up the
stairs and csing to find a way off a
stage his frequent verbal and physical
stumbles are the subject to both comedy
and concern most people responded with
laughter and derision for example when
first lady Jill Biden said this about
him I see Joe every day I see him out
you know traveling around this country I
see his Vigor I see his energy to those
who say I can't vote for Joe Biden he's
too old what do you say I say his age is
an
asset H energy and vigor not quite what
I'm seeing you can make a plausible case
for the wise old Statesman with a firm
hand on the tiller but campaigning on
Biden's Vigor May well FastTrack Donald
Trump who does have a lot of vigor to
the White House Now 77 Trump's no spring
chicken himself but with his diet
defying Swagger and Showmanship most
people on his side seem to be believing
him when he says things like this I feel
like I'm about 35 years old I actually
feel better now than I did 30 years ago
tell me is that crazy I feel better now
and I think cognitively I'm better than
I was 20 years ago I don't know
why that is a slightly more debatable
subject Mr Trump but a whopping 77% of
Americans both Republican and Democrats
believe that Biden is simply too old to
run the country almost 70% think he's
mismanaged the crisis at the southern
border there 133% say they're
financially better off on his watch a
this stage of his term he's the least
popular US president in recorded history
and this stuff matters us politics is
Inc almost hysterically polarized to the
rest of us outside America but most
voters are in fact ready to be persuaded
white working-class voters ditched the
Democrats to propel Trump to office in
2016 now more and more Hispanic and
black voters are shifting Republican too
Biden says he's the only man who's ever
beaten Trump and that's true but right
now he may be the only one who can lose
to Trump in November well I'm joined by
my Super PAC here in the studio New York
co-host of The Breakfast Club
Charlamagne the God host of the Rubin
report Dave Rubin I'm a Democrat
strategist and Fox News contributor
Jessica tof who I could hear her lips
pursing as I read that mon loud I could
feel them person I appreciate though I
saw you tempered it a bit whoever put it
in the pror was harsher than you were I
could feel the pursing I was raining
back in real time um let me start with
you Jessica because I like Joe Biden
personally I think he's got a lot of
very admirable qualities as a human
being and his own story you know the
fact he lost loost his wife and a baby
when he was just a senator he then lost
another son anyone that can do that and
still do the job he's doing will always
have my admiration but there is no doubt
he is in real trouble here is there any
doubt I mean can you paint a picture
that isn't as Grim as the one I painted
oh I definitely can do that and I've
been preparing for three and a half
minutes to get chance I I'm not going to
start by denying that the age factor is
massive in all of this and I think that
people's concerns as well about KLA
Harris and her Readiness to take over
informs that if there was a hugely
popular vice president kind of waiting
in the wings I think things might feel a
bit different for people but 81 is 81
there are some 81 year olds we all watch
Warren Buffett right MC jagu is 80 yes
nearly 81 he would have a different kind
of agenda for the country but yes he
does that be quite a popular one yeah
that would be pretty I wouldn't hate it
um but there is a problem going on right
now with media coverage
of the Biden presidency and there are
problems with the Biden campaign what
are the problems so I'll start with
media coverage everybody knows now that
you want to print stories that get
clicks and negative stories are the ones
that do with it even people who are huge
supporters of the president focus on all
the polls that are negative most people
wouldn't know that if you went to the
real clear politics homepage and clicked
on polls the average has Joe Biden down
just one percentage point to Trump you
would think that he was getting trounced
you look at swing state polls and you'd
see that in a lot of the Swing States
like Pennsylvania for instance which is
going to be a huge deal he's up
massively we only talked about the fact
that he was down in one Michigan poll
last week in terms of the economic news
The Wall Street Journal our very own
Wall Street Journal here at newscorp um
had a hugely optimistic set of
editorials out there 62% of Americans
think the next year so 2024 election
year is going to be better for them when
are they going to go and vote in
November that's a lot of time for this
economic recovery to really settle in
for people but no one wants to talk
about that it's not popular it's not
good clickbait the second part about the
campaign and this is where I think the
Obama folks who have been perhaps too
publicly critical I think of the Biden
campaign their ground game is not
visible to folks they don't feel like
they're there in Nevada in Arizona in
Georgia in these states that we
desperately need to win and they are
working on that and I think that the
president himself needs to be more
visible I if I was working in the white
house I would have him out there all the
time I understand you might be resing
stumble I wouldn't I do what they did
with him last time I keep him keep him
in a dungeon I mean look here's the
thing I think the problem it's not
excuse me it's not his age I think that
Joe Biden's problem is the clear
senility yeah was going with his age
like I said I met mck Jagger last summer
absolutely bursting with the vi and
vigor that Jill wants us to believe she
sees it go look Piers do any of us
sitting at this table or anyone watching
this think that he could run one shift
at McDonald's and I don't mean that as a
shot for someone that works at
McDonald's
there but but I don't think he could I
think a lot of senior citizens could
because I don't think it's an age thing
I agree with you it's it's a cognitive D
J Collins at the Emmys stole the show
he's 90 years old good friend of mine
she looks about 50 and she has the
mental acuity of a 50-year old she has
vim and vigor so I Jill Biden is right
to say it's about VI and vigor but her
husband doesn't exude it well look let's
put it this way you opened by saying
something about ailing Joe Biden and I
thought oh I haven't looked at my phone
in 20 minutes did something it's a
general aing it's ailing yes we all know
it the wandering off when they put get
him off the plane and the confusion he
literally on camera last what was it two
years ago said let's go let's go Brandon
like something is not right we all know
it and I would say respectfully in terms
of the polls and everything people don't
vote on what really matters we vote on
what we can
right and I think because of people are
going Donald Trump he seems back there's
energy there and there's just no energy
with nobody nobody likes Kamala that's
but Trump has lost every election except
2016 I mean he's loser and yeah right
right to the point the Democrats decided
to finish him off with 91 criminal
charges and thought this will do him
he's down he's wounded and and it's had
the complete opposite effect he has used
that to the Marty the victim it has
fueled a resurgent trump and you cannot
deny I mean I've seen people try to
downplay what happened to Iowa but if
that have been Joe Biden who'd done that
at Iowa you'd be saying this is
unbelievable it's a landslide it's
amazing he's killing them right Trump is
back and I think will definitely be the
nominee regard unless there some
extraordinary Twist of events he's
exuding the air of someone on a mission
he's got vim and vigor and whether you
love him or hate him and it's equal
doses with Trump you got to say hey
Trump V Biden in November I could see
Trump winning that is there anything
about Iowa that makes you say maybe uh
Republicans should pivot and go to
somebody like a Nikki Haley maybe like
when you see that she picks up you know
a lot of Democrats a lot of Independents
you think that they're doing themselves
a disservice by maybe not getting behind
her because you know the GOP is going to
fall in line and she's somebody who
seems like they can pick up votes from
from both sides yeah I mean but you
yourself you made news by talking about
the vi Vigor claimed by Joe Biden didn't
you I mean you're yeah I don't see the
vi you're not whatever VI Vigor whatever
it is yeah and I had I had a great time
on your breakfast club show yesterday
and it was it was really enlightening
conversation we had but you know it's
not that I like you said to you are you
telling people to vote Trump no it's not
for me to tell people how to vote in
this country and I've been very critical
of trump in the last since certainly
over all the whole the stolen election
nonsense the January 6th thing I wasn't
buying into any of that and in a way I
felt that was disqualifying but we are
where we are it didn't disqualify him he
could actually go to prison and still be
president of the United States
constitutionally so we're into
completely Uncharted Territory all I do
feel is the more the Democrats have
tried to kill him off particularly with
all these criminal charges the more that
even Republicans that don't like him
have gone you know what it is a Witch
Hunt the Liberals are trying to nail
this guy is one of us we're going to
back him and so it's been self-defeating
MH a bit like the Russian collusion
thing yeah I I agree with that and I
think the interesting thing is if you're
going to use language like you know this
is going to be the end of democracy as
we know it then there needs to be a
sense of urgency like you said when is
the ground game going to start why is
the ground came just starting now if
it's going to be you know the end of
democracy and I think that's what scares
people too if if we see the the clearing
to me anyway to clear and present danger
that could be a second Trump presidency
is the Biden Harris ticket a winnable
ticket I'm a person who voted for Joe
Biden in 2020 so I don't think it's
anything wrong with asking that question
you think it's a winable ticket tick I
don't know when I look at the polls I
don't think so you know I think that uh
a 60 plus year old no incumbent
president with this poll rating that
Biden's currently at in the low 30s has
ever been reelected yeah I don't I don't
I mean yeah when I look at it I don't
think so me you never know you can you
can say it's 50/50 but I think a 60 plus
year old Joe Biden you know with the
things he's done as far as like you know
the infrastructure Bill even even the
student loan forgiveness you know the
way the economy is now I think a 60
something year old Joe Biden Jo he also
said to you he also said to you on your
show which again headlines make a lot of
headlines jealous um but he said if
you're black and you don't vote for me
you're not black he meant it was a joke
but what did you think when he said that
was that was that a sense of entitlement
a bit of arrogance about the
African-American vote I think that you
know he has too many uh black friends
around him and they made him feel
comfortable enough to make that joke I
feel like he probably had a bunch of
black people around him who have said
that exact language cuz when they say
that they're saying that hey if you vote
for Trump you're literally voting you
know against your own interest as a
black person and I think he's heard that
a bunch of times so he thought that that
would been a nice little let me ask you
a specific thing Dave about this right
so Trump this is where I have a problem
with Trump every time I sort of you know
I he makes me laugh right he just does
when he said that thing on the eve of
Iowa that even if it kills you come out
and
vote world yeah but watching watching po
liberals lose their mind when he does
that stuff makes me chuckle right I I've
seen myself as pretty down the middle
but I just think I think he's funny and
he's and he can make people laugh but
when he says this I don't laugh right he
said the president of the United States
on Truth social yesterday president of
the United States must have full
immunity without which it would be
impossible for him her to properly
function any mistake even if well-
intended would be met with almost
certain indictment by the opposing body
at ter men for even events that cross
the line must fall under total immunity
I so I so I tweeted so if President
Biden orders the immediate assassination
of you Donald Trump that's okay is it
that's covered what you're explaining is
the true magic of Donald Trump whether
you love his policies or not because on
one hand you're going well there are
certain lines when he pokes fun at the
but he means this no no so but so your
line now is he put it in quotes crosses
the line I can tell I can tell when I
can tell when he's laughing and joking
So You Think You think when he says
cross the line what he meant was I can
take out Joe Biden president no no that
was me suggesting that that's where you
take the argument but what do you think
he means I think would kill one ofal OPP
or get could I think he's actually as
always with Trump his self-interest he
wants to basically make sure he can't he
means Jack Smith go home yeah that's
what he means and he's and if the cor
alary is my political opponent could
kill someone he then wants to talk about
2016 when we all ran around and said you
know he could shoot someone in the
middle of Fifth Avenue and and his
supporters wouldn't care by this by this
new criteria he could do that and get
away with it right well I think there
are some legal questions as per what a
president is allowed to get away with
and not be but I'm pretty murder is not
one of them like outright
Mur he would like it to be he would like
anything that crosses the line to fall
under total immunity the man has open
agulation for XI Jin for Kim Jong-un he
he's a wannabe dictator and I don't you
know I've been at Fox News my entire
media career I do not fancy myself an
MSNBC type person who wants to lose
their mind about those things but that
is very serious to have someone who was
the leader of the Free World and is
running to be it again to believe that
these people who are athma to democracy
are doing it right what do she feel and
also to though we're acting like you
know it's not just rhetoric yes he said
he want to be a dictator for a day yes
he said you know he should be immune
from killing you know immune from
killing his political Rivals but he also
attempted a CO with his country guys
right like why are we acting like that
did not happen why we keep acting like
January since did not happen I mean it
didn't happen I mean what that a bunch
of people showed up with no plans no
weapons I mean I'm not defending the
people that actually broke windows or
anything else but there was no coup
there was no that was attemped coup this
country I got eyes and ears I'm not a
political expert was plan was there a
plan did anyone have a piece of paper
that said croud boys had a plan and they
were invited into the White House there
were people with zip ties that's not a
casual thing that you walk around with
I'm not they went after the valid Bo
they were talking about hanging there
were a thousand there were only a 100
bad ones let's say that doesn't mean
that it wasn't an attempted CP f by the
president of the United States of
America I mean does anyone honestly
think that Donald Trump thought that the
next day he would be president you know
post transition B potential trans B does
which is why he finally had to go there
are people I mean what was so powerful
about the January 6 committee and what
they were able to put together is the
fact that they used almost exclusively
Republican testimony people who had
worked for him I mean look at the text
messages from his own son to Mark
Meadows or what aanka
had to be honest about when she
testified or Jared Kushner or Cassidy
Hutchinson who they're going after now I
mean he made a mockery of our system and
frankly me it speaks to the strength of
our institutions and the backbone of
Mike Pence for that eight hours that he
was able to I thought it was a pretty I
got to say it was a pretty terrifying
spect I'm sure watching it abroad you
thought what the hell is going on I
remember emailing one of his team and
saying what you've got to get him out
there and call this thing off and he
didn't for a long period of time while
this Mayhem was erupting you can dress
it anywh you like you can spin it
anywhere you like to thousands of people
whipped up into a mindset of we have to
stop this Democratic action happening
stormed into the epicenter of American
politics and they tried to take control
and in their eyes stop democracy
happening now the LI the liberal
response by the way which is to Classic
liberal response which is completely
halfast which to say right let's take
him off the ballot now in loads of
different states is obviously
stupid you don't try and stop a guy you
think has tried to thwart democracy by
thwarting democracy can I tell say two
things one Charlamagne brought up a
point that I wanted to add on to that's
really important about the vien Vigor
right so Donald Trump I don't think that
he's going to trip and fall and die
tomorrow but when people do see him he's
talking absolute rubbish he's he's done
that for 50 years
but people I I agree I and I didn't even
like his shows when it was on regular TV
but my
point come on the 2008 Celebrity
Apprentice was the stuff of
Masterpiece but the kind of
communication that he's putting out
there he's even in the last 48 hours we
went from II I was there I was on air
and I said this is a big accomplishment
for him he's being consilio how long
will it last then we got to immigrants
are poisoning the blood of America then
defaming a woman who he's been charged
they found him guilty of sexually
assaulting her he continues with that
he's talking about how magnets work in
water you know using ID to buy a loaf of
bread it's not like people who are at
home are saying this guy's got it
together and this guy doesn't you know
what is you know what we're gonna come
back I'm going to talk after the break
to De Phillips and keep you guys here to
react to that but also want to talk
about what Jamie Diamond said which I
thought was really interesting when he
said that if you call everyone who a
Maga supporter a supporter of trump if
you call them a bunch of crazies then
you are completely missing the point why
most of them actually want to vote for
Trump which is economy foreign policy uh
the Border all these things which he was
strong on last time he said that's why
they want him back because they feel
they've been let down on that by Biden
we'll talk about that after the break uh
stay with me un sensored next more from
my New York super B I'll be joined by
the Democratic presidential candidate
who wants Joe Biden to stand aside he's
Minnesota Congressman Dean Phillips and
he'll be here live in a couple of
minutes welcome back to PEB uncensored
live from New York City Democrats are
privately threatening about President
Biden's disastrous polling in the race
for the White House very few of them are
prepared to say it out loud only one
elected Democrat has been bold enough to
run against the incumbent president and
US Representative Dean Phillips is that
man and joins me now Mr Phillips thank
you for joining me I guess the first
question for the global audience is who
are you and why do you want to be
president
who am I and why do I want to be
president well I'll tell you my quick
story I lost my father in the Vietnam
War he was a soldier who served his
country and gave his life to our country
uh I got very lucky three years later my
mom remarried I was adopted into a
remarkable family uh one of many
blessings uh including business
philanthropy my grandmother was the
advice columnist Dear Abby uh entered
our family business built Bader vodka
then sold that built tente gelato the
ice cream brand and Piers I woke up the
morning after the 2016 election I found
my youngest daughter in her bedroom in
tears and I recognize life has changed
in America and around the world I
promised them my two daughters I would
do something I ran for congress I
flipped a district that had not elected
a Democrat since 1958 and I beat an
incumbent by who had won by 14 points I
beat him by 12 and I got to the US
Congress in 2019 and found an
unmitigated dysfunctional disaster that
is easily fixed with good leadership
peers and you ask why I'm running for
president well the overwhelming
exhausted majority of Americans center
right center left Americans Common Sense
people are tired of this they want to
turn the page from both Trump and Biden
and I tell you I tried to get the
president to pass the torch I called
other candidates who are better known
than me none of them would do it so I
thought it was time for courage my
father gave his life to this country and
I entered the race because if not now
when and if not me who and I got to tell
you pierce it is a joyful journey and
Americans are not as divided as anger
tainment would have us believe and I'm
going to make change in a common sense
decent way that engages Democrats and
Republicans and moves Beyond dangerous
nonsense well everything you say makes
perfect sense except this Joe Biden if
he doesn't Stand Down will be the
nominee now twice in post second world
war history there has been an incumbent
Democrat president who has done that you
know Lyndon Johnson did it and there was
another president who did it um they
stood down and didn't go forward but if
Joe Biden doesn't do that voluntarily
you have no way
in well appears I don't I don't I don't
buy into that I'll tell you I've spent
my life my professional life disrupting
uh businesses and categories trying to
disrupt the US Congress that is in
desperate need of it and that's why I'm
doing this again as long as American
voters actually get out and vote in the
primary anything is possible Joe Biden's
not a bad man he's a good man but he's
81 years old he's facing the lowest
approval numbers in American
presidential history every poll he's
losing including the Battleground States
and even you know Charlemagne the God
who was just on with you moments ago and
I was on The Breakfast Club just about a
week ago uh he's speaking the truth too
saying the quiet part out loud he's not
electable so Democrats will have a
choice Piers sometime soon to either go
and coronate a candidate who is going to
lose or go with hope and optimism and a
brighter future with a candidate me
who's 54 years old and able willing
competent and ready to combine the very
best of center right center left
thinking in America and stop the
nonsense and win that's the choice of
American voters and we got to practice
democracy not just talk about it all
right look you haven't got much time
give me three things you would do if you
were president tomorrow top priorities
oh let me start with let me let me talk
about executive leadership I will have a
bipartisan cabinet of the best and
brightest Americans Democrats and
Republicans I will have a youth cabinet
I will employ zerob based budgeting I
will actually manage our federal
government in a fiscally responsible
manner uh I will address the southern
border which is an unmitigated
mess and disaster inhumane horrible for
our economy and our International
reputation and we have must reform our
Asylum policies and then I will do what
is most important for Americans right
now costs and Chaos are out of control
life is unaffordable 60% of Americans
living paycheck to paycheck 40% cannot
afford a $400 emergency we've got to
attack affordability we've got to end
the chaos not just in the United States
but all around the world end the wars
invest in peace and bring the country
together and do our best to bring this
world together before it's too late
piers and that's going to take all of us
and by the way as some have noted Jamie
Diamond about Biden condemning all Trump
supporters I welcome and invite Trump
supporters I love everybody as long as
you are people of principal and decency
and want to work together peers we got
to change this nonsense the two parties
are the problem and I'm running for
change and I don't mind that disruption
because I think most people want it well
it's good of you to uh join me Mr
Phillips I would personally say you
probably have two hopes of succeeding no
hope and Bob Hope but I do admire the
aspiration and I actually like the cut
of your jib as well so you never know in
politics right hey you never know you
got to give it a shot and by the way
mark my words watch here in New
Hampshire on January 23rd just four days
from now you might be
surprised I I look forward to it I would
love to be surprised Dean Phillips thank
you very much and for joining me
Charlamagne you got what a Optimist you
are you know what I am I'm I'm an
optimist tinge with being a realist
right you got to be real about this I
don't think Joe Biden has shown any
indication of wanting to stand down at
all unless he voluntarily does that is
persuaded to he is going to be the
nominee right and for someone like you
um you've become with your show various
shows but The Breakfast Club in
particular has this extraordinary number
of young black people who tune in
religiously to listen to it to watch it
and to think what do they want what do
they want from their president I they
got two elderly white guys right running
for president this is not an Obama 20089
scenario what do they want to happen
here well when you talk about it in
those terms number one they want both of
them to step out the way they want the
GOP to move away from Trump they want
you know Democrats to move away from bid
but I don't care who you talk to most
folks you speak to want upward Mobility
like it's all about money like that's
the conversation that they should be
having when they're having conversations
about you know creating jobs when
they're having conversations about the
economy being better that's great but is
it trickling down to the least of us you
know is it trickling down to the hood is
it trickling down to the rural areas
rural areas like where I'm from in Mons
Corner South Carolina if those people
aren't feeling the relief then you know
they feel like you know what you're
doing isn't isn't necessarily what does
you feel about Jamie Diamond who says
that you know if you if you just
ridicule and mock the magga crowd the
the really hardcore Trump supporters
it's wrong that you should respect all
Americans right they're entitled to
their opinion entitled to vote for who
they want to vote for I mean I thought
he had a point he also a point that if
you just over demonize Trump I think I
said on on your show I met Chris Rock
after the 2016 election the next day and
he said is someone's murdered eight
people don't go around saying he's
murdered nine about Trump in other words
you just exaggerate how bad he is it
people are going to find out see that
was 2016 I think in 2024 like we kind of
see what a trump presidency is is like
and how bad it could potentially be what
are you most worried about with him uh
I'm worried about you know uh the threat
to democracy seriously because when you
hear guys say hey we should get rid of
the constitution in order to overturn
the results of election like when you
hear a guy say you hear his lawyers in
court say well he never agreed to uh
support the Constitution it's like whoa
I don't care if you're Democrat
Republican black white gay straight if
you're an American citizen you cannot
have a leader of the Free World who does
not respect the Constitution Dave you
can't have someone who doesn't respect
the Constitution country well first off
the beauty of America and our system and
the Constitution and the rest of our
founding documents is that they work and
we've separated enough so that guys like
Donald Trump potentially if he wanted to
be dictator it's not that you just flip
a switch and suddenly you're dictator
not using the 14 well hold on a second I
would also say that if you look at the
actual reality of Trump's presidency
preco the economy was booming we had the
Abraham Accords lowest all-time black
unemployment lowest alltime Latino
unemployment and you may remember at the
State of the Union when he mentioned
that and AOC and the rest of the
Congressional Black poet sat there like
this I thought they would have been for
low black employment so Trump has done a
lot of things right and I'm saying this
as somebody that wasn't even supporting
him three days ago I mean I'm a disantis
guy I moved to Florida because J diamond
to be look to be clear he's not a big
Trump supporter he's locked he's locked
horns with Trump a few times he's
donated to the Democrats right it's not
and Trump has rubbished him in public
about doing business in China so it's
not like he's a dieh hard Trumper
himself he just made the point which I
think is right which is if you just
abuse everyone that votes for him you
are basically committ an act of self
harm what I would recommend anyone do as
this election keeps going is as the
rallies start again and I did not vote
for Trump in 2016 I did vote for him the
first time but one of the uh the second
time and one of the reasons that I ended
up doing it was one day in La I happened
to drive by a rally and I was like you
know what let me just go in there and
see what's going on and there were black
people and there were Latinos and gays
for Trump and it was a joyfest it was a
party American flags everywhere it
wasn't some coalesced idea of let's take
out democracy or out the Marxist or
anything else it was basically kind of
like an Fu to the system and and then
just this mix of politics I mean that's
the Jessica were you at this party he's
talking
about I wasn't invited there were gays
blacks Latinos but no liberals what did
you think what did you think were an
awful lot of liberal there were four
Bernie Sanders voters who probably
didn't turn up what did you think of
Jamie Diamond's comment because they
were I think Jamie Diamond runs a huge
international business and you can see a
a Line in the Sand with how people who
don't want to lose customers talk about
all of this and they have to do it that
way and that's correct but as someone
who spends my time in conservative media
with people who vehemently disagree with
me I'm I've had it up to here if I could
clutch my pearls any harder you know
whatever it is they try to say that
liberals talk the same way about
conservatives that conservatives talk
about liberals if Donald Trump wins the
presidency again you will have a
president who calls more than half the
country 81 million voted for Joe Biden
74 million for Trump calls us thugs
pedophiles Communists marxists
anti-americans traitors I I'm not being
welcomed into any sort of I have a
question I have a question for you which
I asked Charlamagne yesterday how many
uh
immigrants did Barack Obama Deport in
eight years he's the deporter and- chief
and I've
said milon 2 million he already knows
cuz I told him he got
yesterday I thought it was only two over
3 million it it was the greatest number
Pro rout of any president in history he
did not hurt him with latino voters I
say it all the time on the five Biden
can get tougher about this Henry qu he's
got it right how he's talking about it
the Border dams the mark Kelly of the
world that's all fine and good but to
your point about what this world looked
like or this country before Co Trump
setting all these records guess what
Biden's done better than his records so
black unemployment is lower than it was
under Trump Latino unemployment lower
than under let's talk about oil I can't
even tell you how many times I've been
told you know drill baby drill well Joe
bid's doing it 13.3 million barrels it's
the highest amount of oil produced by
any country in history good sales pitch
but here's the critical question for all
of you and it's a one word one word
answer if it's Biden Trump in November
who no who wins I I do believe Biden
wins
Trump casting votes by the way that's
why that's what's so scary about it like
you have to think by the way you don't
have to want this to happen but you're
talking about I know but you're talking
about a guy who has 91 criminal charges
a guy who says he wants to be a dictator
for a day a guy who says we should rip
up the Constitution do know what day is
and that's what I'm saying so if if
Biden has done all of these great things
and he's up against that and we're still
not sure name is he winnable I don't I
really don't know you got to you got to
give me a name who's going to win Biden
V Trump it's not Dean Phillips it's not
gonna be Dean Phillips I really truly
don't know if I had to say right now I
would say Donald Trump wow there we go
the casting vote Charlamagne the god the
man with his finger on the pulse of
America Trump maybe but I I don't know I
really long feel so scary about it there
a long there's a long time ago brilliant
to have you all thank you very
much